[Música]
homer na china
meu nome bernardina eu nasci no interior
muito interior em 1974 deu entrevista o
flávio cavalcanti falei pra ele assim eu
nasci no interior
aí foi porque essa tá falando entre o
farei porque além de interior interior
hoje estado do rio interior de mim mas
né
só em cidade pequena e eu nasci no
interior não tinha isso não tinha nem
carro de boi
então eu quando eu saí de lá e fui morar
numa cidade por não governador valadares
meu pai era madeireiro e eu ouvia muitas
carretas na nossa porta
carretas de madeira e eu ficava
entusiasmada de ver aquele homem
pequenininho passando marcha num remake
é o alfa romeo caminhão grande
meu deus como é que pode isso eu vi
aquelas mercedinha de casa cumprido ou
para menos e dinheiro fosse longo foi
meu deus que coisa linda e eu queria
estar lá e minha mãe brigava comigo e o
tempo foi passando e eu fui ficando cada
vez mais curiosa pra saber que era
aquilo e comecei a pesquisar a olhar os
caminhões e notícia de pesquisa pela
internet
levantar o capô do caminhão estava
olhando enviava de baixo vi o
diferencial ea caixa
meu deus o que é isso aí eu comecei a
perguntar em meus pais começaram a achar
ruim não pode não pode ver uma menina
mulher no no interior veio aquele monte
de carreteiro né que a fama já não é boa
e eu estava lá não queria nem saber
quanto foi um belo dia a idade maior
chegou a autoridade também eu disse eu
vou embora para o rio de janeiro me
mandei vir para o rio onde eu cheguei no
rio eu já conhecia motor porque eu vi os
caminhoneiro às vezes fazendo aquela
mecânica bruta no meio da estrada ali na
porta de casa
eu comecei a procurar emprego eu quis
até o exército pensando que ela podia
ser mecânica mas não consegui
aí comecei a tentar aquelas oficinas
linhas próximas da onde eu morava
laranjeiras mas como ninguém me dava
atenção
achava até que o meia biruta né porque
parece minuto mas não é absoluta não
gente é gostar do que faz
eu fiquei muito triste quando eu vi
aquela palavra de cinco em cinco anos a
gente muda de profissão eu não mudei até
hoje eu não quero mudar não eu aviso pra
vocês
quando arrumar em minha mala que eu
tiver de ir embora para não mais voltar
não fala de mecânica não eu vou levantar
vocês vão ser tudo olha vou levantar
porque eu gosto de mecânica eu gosto
muito eu amo a mecânica então procurei
procurei procurei não achei até que um
belo dia eu fui a uma firma da mercedes
benz
procurei uma semana duas semana o mês
dois meses três rappin hood o chefe o
técnico
o diretor-técnico assim aquela moça dia
fala com ela que eu vou falar com ela
quando eu cheguei eu falei com a moça
assim inferior menina você fala com seu
chefe que eu vou sentar aqui enquanto eu
não me atendeu não vou embora vou ficar
a semana toda e é sempre na segunda
feira de manhã
um belo dia ele falou isso pra nós e eu
cheguei lá com essa atitude nos dois
estavam com a mesma
ela foi então ele hoje vai atender ele
abriu a porta e me sentou
conversei com ele pela menina que você
faz na mecânica falei olha eu conheço o
motor caixa eu já vi
eu esqueci que entre o motor ea caixa de
embreagem porque eu conheço eles não vão
fazer uma coisa você vai ficar com a
gente
três meses sem ganhar nada
falei 'não posso eu tenho que comer e
vestir
não posso ficar eu vou ficar seis
trabalhando até meio dia
tá bom aí eu fiquei seis meses
mentira quem é esse dias depois de
aparecer 11 técnico da mercedes benz lá
chegou e disse assim ué tem mulher
trabalhando aqui você tem uma moça com a
gente mas não é permitido mas ela é
muito pediu muitos não você quer pra são
paulo e falei ontem então
se fosse pouco ele falou muito e eu
aceitei não levou o mesmo estava dentro
da mercedes vence que me abriu as portas
ela me abriu as portas por isso que às
vezes quando eu falo de mercedes - eu
falo com muito orgulho e satisfação
porque a mercedes me abriu as portas
então disse que mercê de mãe realmente
ela está no lugar de mãe pra mim porque
ela me abriu as portas e eu entrei não
sentei não trabalhei muito
trabalhava e estudava trabalhava e
estudava todo dia e meio de trabalho
melhoria de estudo
e assim foi até que um belo dia eu
voltei para o rio por causa dos filhos
tive que voltar lá e agora fazer o que o
rio de janeiro difícil
aí me deram a oportunidade de trabalhar
numa fila mas se eu tivesse senai senai
que sim na terrível meninos e mais não
me aceitava por nada na vida não pode
você mulher você não pode trabalhar aqui
eu disse mas diretor
eu conheço o motor eu sei que o motor
montado assim embreagem caixa
transmissão diferencial freio eu preciso
de fazer esse curso que é preciso
trabalhar eu tenho um filho pequeno eu
quero cuidar dele mas não pode minha
filha a tá bom
se você for solteira eu falei a cor eu
sou solteira então me trava a certidão
ele isso poderia ter bakri né
eu fui lendo o roxo num cantam me
registrei no outro dia cheguei lá com a
certidão registrou ontem eu falei não
senhor
é porque eu não tinha registro como que
você trabalhou em são paulo
olha eu tenho um nome papai e mamãe noel
tac
[Risadas]
eu fiz e maio quando terminou semae as
portas começaram a abrir mais ou menos
né
aí eu fiquei nessa firma muitos anos
graças a deus só tem uma coisa reclamar
por causa de vocês ao mês
nós mulheres sofre muita discriminação
eu nunca tive minha carteira registrada
por causa de vocês porque se fosse por
nós mulher hoje eu seria a aposentada
como mecânico não sou porque a minha
idade já é muito pequena e eu não pude
me registrar como mecânica a o
autoritarismo que vocês têm sobre nós
não me deixou ser registrada como
mecânica mas eu sou mecânica
eu tenho uma carta da mercedes e eu
tenho um certificado do senai eu tenho
um certificado polyart eu tenho um
certificado até do instituto universal
brasileiro
já pensou eu registrado no instituto
universal brasileiro isso em 1909 alguma
coisa não pensa agora não mas graças a
deus hoje eu já tenho algumas
entrevistas algumas passagens como
mecânica nem eu acho a coisa mais
gostosa do mundo é muito bom cheiro do
óleo diesel
o cheiro da gasolina o cheiro da graxa
as juntas do cabeçote do diferencial e
almoço cinética ea gente vai pensando
nisso e vai vendo que ser mecânica é
maravilhoso é olha pra mim é uma dádiva
de deus porque é uma coisa que me deu
hoje o estatuto da velhice ou vocês aqui
todos parada me ouvindo né falar de quê
mecânica mecânica mecânica no andar não
mecânica de motor o motor a explosão
mecânica de que mecânica diferencial
pinhão coroa sated planetária que
maravilha
vocês sabem disso seus conhecidos
não perdendo você está bonita
você só bonita a tecnologia está aí você
já pensou você chamada para apresentar
uma mercedes nova que saiu você chamada
para apresentar um volvo você chamada
pra apresentar qualquer automóvel itália
naquele pátio lindo com aqueles carros
maravilhosos né
aí chega um homem diz assim eu estou
querendo comprar um carro
eu não sei de sortear um carro de
quantas toneladas
a gente às vezes pergunto a pessoa
quantas toneladas em um carro quando eu
também estou lá até mesmo esquece até
que conta uma tonelada mil quilo um
carro carrega 40 em 2030 né
as pessoas não sabem por quê a mecânica
me ajudou a aprender isso aí você só
assim ela deve ser uma mulher que estou
muito né não amor não estudei não eu
conhecia mecânica
eu sabia o que era óleo diesel e
gasolina
meus primeiros carros que eu usei para
trabalhar pra ver porque o lugar na
frente da casa do meu pai era carro como
a nicola acho que você não sabe o que é
meu amigo sabe sabe que é manicure
tem gente aqui que só isso isso dava
cada projetada nos braços o rival né
hoje em dia quase que nem mais precisa a
chave de ignição é porque a tecnologia
está avançada na mesma
aí eles assim você é contra a tecnologia
não há injeção eletrônica a gente
precisa mas mecânica não muda não gente
por favor um êmbolo oab é lucas filho
manoel de segmento e o que eu já falei
mais de diferencial caixa coroa pinhão
nada lhe a fama da nós precisamos
estudar mecânica para quando a gente
montar o carro quando vou fazer a parte
de alimentação
a gente sabia da injeção eletrônica da
bomba injetora que naquela época nós já
foi não existia não é então a gente
precisa disso
é muito bom ser mecânica é eu amo a
minha profissão não tenho inveja de
nenhum mecânico
já trabalhei em grandes firmas já tive
na maré
é porque sua mecânica já estive na
aeronáutica porque sua mecânica
já estive no imagino que sua mecânica já
estive fora do brasil porque a sua
mecânica então que a mecânica pra mim
faz parte de mim não é aquela menina lá
do interior viajar para fora do país 11
horas de avião por causa de mecânica
está deitada dormir alguém se o me
socorre meu carro quebrou diferencial em
itaguaí paracambi japeri mangaratiba e
levo isso não é um orgulho pra mim claro
que foi um orgulho com muita lágrima
mas hoje hoje eu conto pra você sorri
porque é uma maravilha então quando o
carro chega não rebocado
não é com diferencial no lugar tudo
muito bem a casa ladinho que a gente tem
no nosso trabalho de mecânica uma coisa
chamada metrologia que muitos meninos
não querem estudar matemática matemática
é muito excessivo a mecânica não tem
matemática não é mecânico é mecânico
porque não sabe medir
então ele não pode trabalhar de mercado
todo na mecânica tem que ter medida
então dirigente estuda metrologia
eu falo pra eles é a matemática
decrescente é muito mais complexa eu
acho do que a matemática como um
crescente 123 o hotel - isso então a
gente tem essa facilidade de falar de
mecânica porque foi uma coisa que eu
vivi a vida toda as vezes alguém me
pergunta quem a sua família mecânico
ninguém
eu fui a primeira mulher mecânica da
família sou até hoje eu fui a primeira
mulher da família que tirou a
habilitação
hoje já tem uma porção de motorista com
carros muito bonito mas eu fui a
primeira que tirei a dirigia um
fusquinha está maravilhoso foi ótimo foi
maravilha
então quer dizer a mecânica é muito
importante pra nós mecânica explosão
o mecânico de motor diesel mecânico
motor gasolina eu não gosto de trabalhar
com o carro a gasolina com o carro ao
congo eu gosto da mecânica diesel porque
tem um ditado que fala assim a gente
deixa o couro mas carrega o ouro
a mecânica de carro leve você deixa
o ouro não carrega nada porque o dono do
carro assim que é isso que vai cobrir
toda a fazer esse motor melhor vender o
carro
vou te pagar à venda o carro então eu
vou trabalhar com diesel porque me dá
dinheiro não é isso que a gente precisa
do dinheiro e vi eu não sou egoísta
ainda hoje me fizeram uma pergunta se eu
dou aula de graça já bem
hoje eu cobre o caríssimo caríssimo eu
cobro 150 reais por mês
é muito caro não é pra dar uma profissão
digna reconhecida e muito boa mas não
fiquem mulheres pensando que eu sou
iludida
não eu acho que nós precisamos ser
mecânicas nós precisamos de ganhar bem
pra cuidar da nossa família
olha o tempo tá indo embora o relógio
para não para
ele não pára é igual eu quando tem um
motor para entregar eu falo que eu
entrego 34 ao relógio vai embora para
ele vai parar não
então a gente vai ficar assim um dia de
s
eu vou fazer uma reunião de mulheres pra
mim fazer vocês gostarem de mecânica
por que vocês precisam chegar e dizer
que seu marido não vou sair desse carro
que esse carro está com esse problema eu
tenho certeza porque dona regina ensinou
a vovó falou pra mim que isso é um
defeito eu não vou sair com esse carro
mandar consertar ele tá bom assim
nós somos entendido ficaram satisfeito
ai que pena que olha
[Aplausos]
eu só vou dizer pra vocês
boa tarde que deus abençoe vocês que
vocês sejam sempre assim mas que punham
na cabeça
nós precisamos trabalhar e profissão de
mulher e mecânica mecânica essa é a
nossa profissão tá bom a gente que deus
abençoe vocês precisavam de mim vocês
podem pedir meu contato que eu estou
pronta para atender também que deus
abençoe todos de bom pra vocês no abraço
[Música]